i thought i'd start by talking about
what would happen if there wasn't the
greenhouse effect just to try and
convince you that there is a greenhouse
effect here's a picture of what the
world would look like with no greenhouse
effect so you've got the sun shining
down on the earth mainly sort of optical
wavelength so relatively short
wavelengths and you can calculate how
much energy that delivers to the earth
and it's a slightly complicated
calculation because some fraction of the
sunlight gets reflected off clouds some
of it gets reflected straight back from
snow doesn't get absorbed by the earth
sometimes the sun's below the horizon
sometimes the sun's not directly
overhead but nonetheless you can factor
all those things in but a certain amount
per unit area arrives at the earth
that's called like f and that warms up
the earth the earth gets warmer and
warmer
the net effect when something warms up
is it starts giving out radiation itself
and so the earth is going to warm up to
a point where it's giving out radiation
and the amount of radiation it gives out
depends on the temperature by a thing
called stefan's law which basically says
that the amount of energy that the earth
then re-radiates back into space is
given by that formula where this thing
is stefan's constant sigma and then this
is the temperature of the earth t zero
to the fourth power and of course what's
going to happen is things are going to
keep heating up and heating up and as
the earth heats up of course this number
gets bigger and bigger which means
eventually you reach a point of
equilibrium where there's as much energy
coming in as there is going out and so
that should then dictate what the
equilibrium temperature of the earth
actually is and if you stick the numbers
in it turns out that the temperature you
get out is about 255 kelvin which is
minus 18 centigrade um which is pretty
chilly and so clearly we're missing
something so that should that's like the
default temperature that the earth
should be with the sun where it is and
absolutely that's the in fact
interestingly it is about the
temperature of the moon the average
temperature of the moon is about minus
80 minus 20 centigrade
because the moon doesn't have an
atmosphere and so that really is the end
of the story as far as a body like the
moon's concerned clearly the earth is
not at minus 18 degrees centigrade and
that's where the greenhouse effect kicks
in and keeps us nice and warm okay so
now i need another picture so the
complicating factor is that we have an
atmosphere so the atmosphere
interacts with radiation and in
particular it tends to be better at
absorbing longer wavelengths of light
and so to a first approximation the
sunlight that's coming down just comes
straight down through the atmosphere
and doesn't really care and i've here
let's really simplify the atmosphere
let's treat the atmosphere as if it were
just a thin layer or at least a bit of
the atmosphere that's doing the
greenhouse effect let's just treat it as
just a single thin layer you can think
of it as like a window pane if you like
that actually lets normal wavelengths of
light optical wavelengths of light
through but is very good at absorbing
infrared light why didn't it get
absorbed on the way in so because the
wavelengths are different right because
the the sunlight is mostly optical light
and the radiation that the earth are
missing is mainly infrared and various
gases like water vapor and carbon
dioxide are very good at absorbing
infrared but they're basically
transparent to optical light like a
one-way street yeah or actually like a
sheet of glass because a lot normal
glass is very lets optical light through
but actually absorbs infrared light so
it really is you know it behaves in much
the same way as a sheet of glass does
what's the story here well we've got the
same radiation coming down to the earth
f and then we don't know how much it
heats the temperature up on the surface
of the earth yet so let's give it a
different name for what we gave it
before so it's gonna if it heats it up
to some temperature t1 let's call it so
we had t0 before
then the radiation it gives out
gets bounced back up it heats up this
layer of gas in the atmosphere of course
the same thing is going to happen there
right it's going to heat up and heat up
and heat up and as it heats up it's
going to start radiating itself
and so it's actually going to start
producing radiation depending on its
temperature the slight difference of
what we have before of course is this
layer has two sides which means that
some of it gets radiated downwards and
some gets radiated upwards in fact
because it's symmetric you get the same
amount coming down it's going up and for
the equilibrium that we had before we
know what this temperature has to be
because we know that the amount of
energy coming in the f we had before the
amount of energy coming in has to be
equal to the amount of energy which is
ultimately making it out from the
picture we had before we know what that
equilibrium is that we actually just end
up with the t 0 we had before and that
would balance the f coming in so now to
balance the f coming in that means this
layer needs to heat up to some
temperature t 0
so that the energy coming out is sigma t
0 to the fourth
but because this layer radiates both
ways that also means it radiates back
down again
an amount of energy sigma t 0 to the
fourth as well and we know what the
number needed to make things come out
right in this case is because it has to
be the same amount of energy coming in
this is the only source of energy
escaping
so the amount of energy coming in has to
be equal to the amount of energy coming
out and we've already done the
calculation for that we know that this
layer has to heat up to minus 18 degrees
centigrade to produce the right amount
of outgoing energy so that was doing the
kind of the sums for this layer up here
but we can do the sum at ground level
now which is that we know that the
amount of energy coming in has to be
equal to and now we've got two sources
of energy coming in because there's the
energy that's radiated back down again
as well as the stuff that's coming
straight from the sun has to be equal to
the amount of energy coming out energy
coming in is equal to f but we already
know that f from what we had before is
equal to sigma t 0 to the fourth so
we've got energy in sigma t 0 to the
fourth that's coming in and then there's
another sigma 2 0 to the fourth coming
from the stuff that's radiated back down
again from the layer above our head so
we've got two lots of that
is equal to the energy that's going out
sigma
t1 to the power four
and then we can do a little mathematics
of just cancellating cancelling the
sigmas on both sides and then we need to
take a fourth root of both sides which
tells us that t1 is equal to so we take
the full through to that t to the one
quarter power
t zero which works out it's about 1.2
times t zero so this is saying that the
actual temperature that the earth heats
up to because of this kind of blanketing
layer above our heads is about 20 higher
than it would have been in the absence
of anything above our heads and that
works out if you go through the mass
again you have to do everything in
kelvin rather than centigrade it works
out that the ultimate the temperature of
the earth would end up being about 30
centigrade
so we've kind of overcooked it a bit
because the average temperature of the
earth isn't about 30 centigrade but you
can see that by this mechanism you can
easily make the surface of the earth
heat up much more we haven't broken any
laws of physics to do this various
people kind of think that this breaks
the second law of thermodynamics or one
of those other things it really doesn't
you can see all the heat flow here it's
always heat is flowing from hotter
things to cooler things there's no
energy being created anywhere in this
process it's just redistributing the
energy a bit and also it seems that
you've assumed this layer is very
perfect like a like it takes everything
in like there's no leakage
that's true and in fact if you make it
so that you know you could make it so
that instead of absorbing all everything
that comes in it could absorb a certain
fraction of it and it turns out by
tuning that parameter you can change
this 1.2 factor down to actually get the
surface temperature of the earth right
it's probably not the right thing to do
because we've clearly got a very
simplified model of what's going on in
the atmosphere here
and really this is just to illustrate
the kind of the size of the effect you
can get just by putting a blanketing
layer above the earth but it captures
some of the essential physics of what's
going on so what does it capture it
captures the fact that the real balance
the so the you know if you if you do the
naive calculation then you end up with
your minus 18 degrees centigrade that
balance has to be there but the
important thing to be aware of is that
balance is between the energy coming in
and the energy where it's last kind of
leaving the earth so the the layer from
which the energy actually escapes so
that is indeed you know the balance that
you would expect that the energy in is
equal to the energy out which means this
layer ends up at minus 18 degrees
but then in order to get the energy back
from the ground to here the second law
of thermodynamics essentially says that
in order to get heat to travel from here
up to here this ground has to be at a
higher temperature than that layer there
so that's the reason why you end up with
a higher temperature on the ground than
that naive minus 18 degree centigrade is
because you somehow have to get the
energy from that layer to the point
where it's radiated back into space
we've clearly cheated quite dramatically
here to get this picture though a couple
of the missing pieces of physics one is
that i kind of drew this as if the only
way the energy gets back out away from
the surface of the earth is by radiation
turns out there are other processes that
get the
heat from the surface of the earth up at
least through the lower levels of the
atmosphere like what well the probably
the most important one is actually is
convective effect so actually taking
parcels of air and then just physically
moving upwards
and what happens when a parcel of air
moves is that so you've got a parcel of
warmish air at ground level as it rises
the pressure of the air around it
decreases so it expands
and when you take a gas and expand it it
actually cools thing called a adiabatic
expansion it's just basically as you
expand it it cools down similarly if
you've got a sinking parcel of air as it
sinks down the pressure around it
increases and it gets compressed
and if you've stuck your thumb over the
end of a bicycle pump and pushed the
pump in you know that when you compress
the gas in there it actually heats up
you can feel your thumb getting warm
same here the heat as it sinks
will naturally heat up
that creates a kind of a temperature
gradient so as well as transporting
energy around that you're lifting energy
up and bringing you know hot air rising
cooler air sinking but actually that in
itself will create a temperature
gradient in the atmosphere that as
things lower they tend to increase in
temperature as they go up and expand
they cool
that creates a thing called the
adiabatic lapse rate which just
basically means that as you go up
through the atmosphere the temperature
cools down just naturally nothing to do
with radiation processes just to do with
the kind of the gas physics that's going
on it's a little further complicated
because there's water vapor in the
atmosphere and actually water can also
transfer energy around because water can
go from its liquid form to its vapor
form so there are other processes that
that move energy around but the the the
important aspect for this discussion is
actually as well as the moving energy
around that create a temperature
gradient in the atmosphere turns out
that that simple calculation of the
adiabatic lapse rate isn't quite right
because of the water vapor and all those
other things it works out that the
temperature as you go up through the
earth's atmosphere drops by about six or
seven degrees centigrade for every
kilometer you go up just because of
these physical processes is going on in
the atmosphere so that's why it's cold
when you go up into the mountains
exactly and it really the the main
driving physics is exactly this effect
that as air expands as it rises it cools
down and so that means that that every
time you go up a kilometer it'll be
about six and a half degrees cooler on
average
so that's one part of the physics we're
missing the other part of the physics
we're missing is this blatant cheat of
putting all those greenhouse gasses in a
single thin layer whereas actually of
course they've spread through the
atmosphere like all the other gases are
and it turns out when you put those two
factors in this lapse rate the rate at
which the temperature is going down as
you go above the atmosphere and the fact
that the greenhouse gases are kind of
distributed through the atmosphere that
actually gives you a much more a fuller
picture of what's going on with the real
physics behind the greenhouse effect
here's an attempt at a slightly more
realistic picture of what's really going
on what i'm trying to draw here is a
kind of a cartoon view of the atmosphere
so the dots are all the molecules in the
atmosphere and the red dots are the
greenhouse gases so the things that
absorb the infrared radiation as they're
trying to get out you heat up the ground
the ground starts transferring that
energy back up some of it through
convection some of it through radiation
some of it through the water cycle so
basically the energy starts making its
way up through the atmosphere
eventually it reaches a point where it
can escape from the atmosphere so it's
like as if you were in a forest as
you're walking through the forest when
you're near the middle of the forest all
you see are trees in every direction
eventually you get close enough to the
edge of the forest that you can actually
see your way out of the forest you know
start seeing the the space beyond it's
the same story here you've got radiation
bouncing around
in the
when it's all the way down here it just
can't see you know it keeps bouncing
into where whichever way it goes it hits
a a greenhouse gas molecule so it really
can't see the edge but eventually you
reach a point where you're high enough
in the atmosphere there's less there's
little enough of that gas above your
head the infrared radiation can just
escape out there into space and it it's
this level from which it's escaping so
we've got the same energy balance as
before this is where the energy is
ultimately escaping into space and that
energy escaping has to be equal to the
energy coming in so this is the level of
the atmosphere that you have to heat up
to that minus 18 degrees centigrade in
order to get the balance between the
energy coming out and then the energy
coming in if you're an astronomer you'd
refer to it as a photosphere it's kind
of the the radius if it were a star it's
the radius within a star from which
radiation is escaping but it's kind of
it's that sort of last scattering
surface it's where the radiation can
actually escape from it's at a certain
altitude exactly and that's the altitude
at which you end up with a temperature
of minus 18 degrees all right so now
let's do the experiment of introducing
more greenhouse gas into the atmosphere
so it's exactly the same story as before
that the radiation comes down heats up
the atmosphere but what you can see is
because there's now more red dots you
have to get higher up in the atmosphere
to reach the point where actually you'll
no longer have a red dot above your head
so actually higher in the atmosphere to
reach the point where you can escape so
the only thing that's changed is the the
altitude at which you you reach that
point of balance where the radiation is
getting out and remember that's the
altitude that has to be at minus 18
degrees but the other thing that we saw
before is that actually as you go up
through the atmosphere the temperature
drops by an amount which is kind of set
by the properties of the atmosphere of
about six and a half degrees per
kilometer you go up another way of
thinking about that is to say if you
come down through the atmosphere for
every kilometer you come down the
temperature goes up by six and a half
degrees
so that means that the difference
between these two pictures
is that in the upper one
you don't have very many kilometers to
go down which means that it's minus 18
degrees here and it's not very many
kilometers which means each time you go
down a commodore it goes up by six and a
half degrees it's not going to be that
much above minus 18 degrees by the time
you get to the ground
here because that minus 18 degree point
is way up above your head then there are
many more kilometers to come down to
which means that each time you go down
you go up by another six and a half
degrees that means the ground's
temperature here is going to be much
higher than the ground's temperature was
here just because you've gone up by many
more lots of six and a half degrees than
you did in the first picture that's why
the temperature of the surface is
sensitive to how much of the greenhouse
gas there is above your head
because the more greenhouse gas there is
above your head the further above your
head that minus 18 degree centigrade
level is which means when you come back
down through the atmosphere
you end up with a higher temperature
when you get to the ground than you do
when that minus 18 degree layer is
closer to the ground what happens is you
just keep adding heat and adding heat
and adding heat and making things warm
up until you reach that equilibrium
so you're just adding energy to the
earth essentially until it manages to
reach an equilibrium so the you've got
when it's 30 degrees on the surface
you've cleared you've got more energy
stored in the earth than you had before
but you've got plenty of time to collect
it it just gathers it from the sun over
time it's just it's better at holding on
to it when you've got that kind of
blanket above your head so nothing i've
said here is particularly controversial
in that actually the physics is of all
this is pretty well understood the
controversial part is
how sensitive the atmosphere is to the
addition of extra greenhouse gas and in
particular carbon dioxide the reason why
that's not as straightforward to
calculate as it would appear from what
i've just waved my hands about and
explained
is that actually
the addition of the carbon dioxide is
not the whole story for example
if you were to add a certain amount of
carbon dioxide to the atmosphere it
would heat things up a bit but then what
else happens you've made the atmosphere
a bit warmer
that means that actually it can hold on
to more water vapor well actually if you
make air hotter it can actually have
more water vapor in it water vapor is
another very strong greenhouse gas so
suddenly we've got another greenhouse
gas being added to the atmosphere you
might imagine if you warm things up a
bit you might melt the snow for example
like some of the snow and ice that's
actually reflecting sunlight back
straight back into space so suddenly now
the earth is absorbing more energy than
it was before
you might change the amount of clouds
and it's not clear whether you increase
them or decrease them again that can
just reflect sunlight straight back up
again so
there are kind of knock-on effects of
adding more co2 to the atmosphere
generally they're they they make things
worse or warmer depending on your
perspective so there's kind of an
amplifying effect the sort of a feedback
effect an amplifying effect and all the
argument about how much the earth will
warm up as we add more co2 to the
atmosphere is all to do with how big
those amplifying effects are there is
still quite a range of uncertainty as to
what that sensitivity is when you add a
certain amount more carbon dioxide to
the atmosphere how much the temperature
goes up
isn't because of the physics i've just
been talking about it's because of all
those knock-on consequences which are
quite complicated naively you kind of
might think that this is how a
greenhouse works because a greenhouse is
covered in glass glass has this property
that it lets optical light through but
absorbs infrared
so you could have a picture of a
greenhouse whereby you've got the
sunlight coming in letting the energy in
through it and then
it warms up the ground inside the
greenhouse that then re-radiates but is
trapped by the glass because it can't
get through which is very much like the
picture we were talking about for the
greenhouse effect
turns out that's not the main process in
greenhouses and people have even done
the experiment there are particular
kinds of glass you can make which are
transparent to infrared
radiation and if you made a greenhouse
out of glass which is transparent to
both optical and infrared radiation if
that was what gold was going on the
greenhouse wouldn't work anymore it
turns out greenhouse still gets nice and
warm even if you make it out of this
special glass and it's really because
actually because there are these other
processes that transfer energy around
and in particular this convective thing
this movement of air that's what really
heats up a greenhouse that as the air
heats up in the greenhouse it would like
to rise
and take that heat away but it can't
because the greenhouse keeps it in and
that's really the main physics of why
greenhouses get warm so it's the
trapping of the air not the trapping of
the energy in the light exactly and
actually inhibiting one of these other
processes that transfers energy around
convection not actually inhibiting
radiation as the reason why greenhouses
get warm
talk to me about venus we always venus
is famously portrayed as this runaway
greenhouse effect is that true yeah so
that's very bad news in principle you
can reach a point where as you heat up
the air it can actually have more water
vapor in it it can hold more water vapor
which increases the greenhouse effect if
things are very bad you can get into a
situation where if you had a planet with
oceans on it it starts to heat up the
oceans start to evaporate
that increases the greenhouse effect
which means that the surface gets warmer
which means that warm water evaporates
which means that the thing gets hot and
so you can have this kind of runaway
feedback process and it's thought what
happened with venus is that once upon a
time venus had oceans rather like the
earth it got into this bad cycle of this
runaway greenhouse effect which
effectively just evaporated the entire
oceans and you ended up with this
incredibly high temperature the
inhabitants of venusaur or rather were
far in advance of us in the applications
of physics it's a slightly strange
picture because if you look at venus's
atmosphere now there's essentially no
water vapor in it that picture sounds
completely rubbish right because i've
just told you the reason why it ended up
so hard is because there's lots of water
vapor in the atmosphere but actually
there isn't today the extra piece of
physics is having done that
then what happens is as the water vapor
ends up high in the atmosphere it
photodissociates the hydrogen then
fritters out into space because it's
very light it escapes very easily the
oxygen then combines with carbon to
create carbon dioxide and so you end up
with conventional greenhouse gases
the other bad news for venus is because
you've eliminated all the oceans one of
the good things that the earth's oceans
do is that they're very good at
absorbing carbon dioxide of course on
venus we've just evaporated all the
oceans so any carbon dioxide that's been
created by volcanoes and any other
processes just stays there in the
atmosphere the other thing that hammed
in venus is it doesn't have any plate
tectonics which also might be related to
the absence of oceans and again plate
tectonics because they kind of suck rock
down into the core of the planet or
another good way of getting rid of your
carbon having
lost all its oceans and ended up very
hot because of that
then all the water vapor ended up going
away but the greenhouse effect didn't
because then carbon dioxide really took
over is the big danger that your
photosphere gets so high
that you start boiling water on the
surface of your planet it's not quite
boiling it's just evaporating so just
like water you know well below boiling
point you're losing water vapor off the
surface but it is exactly that that
things heat up of the surface to a point
where you're losing the water vapor so
quickly that you get into this runaway
cycle of creating more and more
greenhouse gases the people who are
looking at greenhouse gases and what
have you on earth the ipcc are pretty
definitive that we're nowhere near that
point right we're not going to have a
runaway greenhouse effect so
all despite all the doom and gloom you
hear this is at least one extremely bad
thing where we're still a long way from
it happening so there's plenty of other
bad things that would happen first but
at least we're not near that point for
the earth
thanks for watching this video if you'd
like to see more about weather phenomena
with professor merefield we've done a
few now i'll put a link to a playlist on
the screen and down in the video
description
also in the description are linked to
our patreon page and a couple of
podcasts that i've been doing lately you
might want to check out
we'll see you here again soon for
another video on 60 symbols